hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm samantha
she fell we're gonna review the trailer
today for a kidnapping mr. Heineken is
he a big beer I hope so that's Anthony
Hopkins in Sam Worthington rated R for
language throughout [ __ ] that's not a
very exciting rated-r thing for me I
like it when it says like strong sexual
content and violence and absurd nudity
and teens drinking something yeah not
there's some bad language going on in
this film the two ways a man can be rich
in this world you have a lot of money or
he can have a lot of friends they cannot
have books
this year I refuse to be miserable so I
want to talk to those less than business
big how big sixty million
you wanna kidnap we're gonna do this we
have to make sure that the cops was in
the wrong direction so job like this
months of preparation state has to hold
in military-grade weapons
you know that what you're doing is
completely stupid and get too personal
he'll get inside your head must be some
confusion if you tell the police where I
am I could be have to run this is
plastic five days to this point again if
your people don't pay soon I can't
answer for my people that's the way the
game is played say
coming big buzzer battery you want to
give up tonight regenexx never the same
well that was more exciting than bad
language Oh with guns there's guns
there's crying yeah should have made a
radar for that I feel like it's almost
like an Ocean's eleven but for
kidnapping Ocean's eleven for kidnapping
more gritty and violent yes it is more
gritty and violent not as funny what I
really walked away from with this
trailer is Anthony Hopkins actually I
like watching a penny Hopkins kind of
play people who taught others and stuff
like that he's he's really good at it
he's [ __ ] great at taunting people I
would love to get enough like making fun
of war with him on something or I'd love
to gang up on someone he's so witty it
the way he handles me it's a nervous
skin too and there's so much life and
performance like going on in him and
there's always an authenticity at the
same time I'm excited to see Anthony
Hopkins in that role and I think Sam
Worthington is a really good actor too
the dynamics between them like you get a
glimpse of it in the trailer but I was
like that's what I'm really looking
forward as the actors interacting with
each other in that moment cuz you got a
lot of great actors in there you got gin
sturgeon surges I love ryan Kwanten from
[ __ ] True Blood he's so good in that
role he's so good and I've been wanting
to see I know he's the Knights of
Badassdom and I've been wanting to see
another role with him that is like yes
cuz he's a fantastic actor you know of
course Anthony Hopkins so I'm thinking
like they got one hell of a cast
assemble this looks like it could be
edgy and thrilling I like how it's not
some overblown like Hollywood project
yes that's the only how to say that as I
agreed yes the beginning of it is where
I felt like it had to set up with
Ocean's eleven and it made me a little
weary like ah but then as a trailer
continued as they got to that halfway
through and whatnot it was like okay
this is grittier this does have
something new about it these guys have
looked like they've done crime before
but yeah they're not the most
professional when it comes to what
they're trying to do now it does make it
for a more interesting dynamic because
these are guys with muscle and certain
intentions and guns and then you gotta
have any Hopkins who has
mind that can really [ __ ] with them so
if they write the role well I'm Anthony
Hopkins like being able to sort of
manipulate the situations they soft this
kidnapping that would be a really
interesting film hoping it really is
more about characterization than it is
about an actual kidnapping like thing
going on like you could either go for
the kidnapping thrills or you could go
for a cool characterization if this film
that combines both holy [ __ ] it could be
powerful the feeling I'm getting is that
there's this setup with a lot of tension
there's a ticking clock you know and you
put anybody on a time limit and like a
short time frame with high stakes shit's
bound blow up yeah I mean I think the
key to a good script is having sort of
that time limit on it that's what keeps
you on the edge of your seat you don't
know what's gonna happen exactly exactly
but it doesn't look overdone in that
sense though yeah that's what I mean
it's like they got these wonderful
actors to come on board the fact that
they have these actors is I'm hoping
they just really take advantage of the
cast rather than going to be like cuz
Ocean's eleven is more about like the
thrill image more of the fun a Hollywood
movie yeah this looks a little like you
said it might be more of a character
it's more like a dramatic thriller yeah
I'm actually on board yeah I totally
check this film out for sure let's see
what happened anyway guys thanks for
checking out this video and telling me
this video is out cuz you guys are
awesome you know what's what you like
watching us check out videos that
already if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you can check out Samantha actually fell
channel some fun [ __ ] on there check
that [ __ ] out what a fit Lola don't
worry I won't make a joke about people
[ __ ] on your chest in this video and
he just did go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shoutouts earned yourself a
shout-out by saying something
interesting February
oh there gonna be some shout outs more
consistently I can't wait
I can't do it it's an LTL do you want
for you there yeah I did from your side
so it's good I got you ah pubic hair cuz
of my beard